if you guys had to pick two of the three
looks money and loyalty what would you
pick
looks in loyalty look some loyalty I
I based on your answers earlier that's
what what do you think
um looks and money some money
loyal to your buddy
look some money
loyalty and money
loyalty and money loyalty and money so
for the people that says they they'd
give up loyalty why I think you said
that and you said that because loyalty
is measured under the benefit of the
doubt and to be honest every single
human that is raised in a modern society
put them in a right scenario they would
basically be not loyal to you
you think the same yeah I think the same
I mean
I feel like at some point
someone's probably going to cheat on you
so I rather cry in a Ferrari than a
fiesta to be honest
have um have you ever been cheated on
no no never have you ever been cheated
on I have yeah how'd you find out
I'm very good at identifying red flags
very good
so what happened
before you found out yourself was it was
it was it a phone phone looker
um no that was actually very quite Brave
about it okay a story
um my partner at the time actually
cheated right in front of my face and I
thought they were joking wait what yeah
okay was it at a bar no so they
basically kept on requesting for a
threesome and I declined couple times
but then I thought I mean the second
time I actually got really mad like
physically mad with that person but they
answered me the third time I thought is
this a joke like we got into a big
argument the first time physical
argument the second time and I answered
me again a third time I thought okay
cool this is a joke I said yeah no
problem
sarcastic yeah no no problem I was like
yeah I said yeah no problem
he actually picked up the female and
booked a hotel I honestly thought he was
joking and I didn't realize
okay I realized he wasn't joking when he
picked her up but then he started to
kiss her in the car and at that point I
was shocked and I thought to myself let
me actually see if he's gonna actually
have sex
how was he supposed to know but it
wasn't no if you said yes
I was being very very sarcastic you can
tell in my voice that I was really
joking especially
no I'm in common now after the third
time and I'm now saying yes after and we
had an argument and a physical I just
thought he was persuasive he's like you
know what she thought no he was trying
to see how how you would yeah
yeah he was testing your boundaries 100
how far did they go with this oh they
went all out I had to sit there and
watch oh my God my pigs I hope you threw
him in the bin of course yeah of course
good of course
oh Lord
yo wow
wait wait wait so what they've done the
full shebang in front of you in front of
me and you didn't do nothing how did you
sit there though
did you did you say at any point that
you weren't okay with it during this no
I mean you could tell by my body
language
it's like someone's saying that they're
gonna do a threesome sarcastically and
you're having sex with someone and
they're literally just in one corner of
the room
say that sarcastically though then yeah
how could you say you're gonna have a
threesome sarcastically I want to know
this guy this guy just thought this was
his chance
thought you were serious
he he literally just took the piss that
I don't think he respected you at all
for him to do that yeah after just
honestly no it depends how it went
because obviously if you're in a
relationship and you agree to it yeah
but she's fantastically yeah
she really thinks a man's gonna be so
amazing friend when you're in a
relationship
you when you started like if I wasn't
okay with it I'd be like what the hell
are you doing from the beginning yeah
sorry so if you're saying nothing like
you don't think that's confusing to the
guy no no because your partner knows you
like my partner knows me I don't even
have to talk and he knows I'm in a bad
mood like your partner should know you
and you said what you said he should
have been like oh [__] I'm in trouble
I should read minds and not listening
her mouth no men just need to stop they
should they should just know you yeah
men should just stop gaslighting us and
pretending that they're dumb because
you're not dumb you know what you're
doing you're testing her boundaries no
but if you're in a relationship right
I'm not saying I've done this because I
haven't and say a guy is genuinely
interested in that kind of aspect okay
then you have not disrespectful if he
feels that way I don't know but yeah
there's obviously a miscommunication
breakdown yeah if he's gone all the way
like something wrong something's not
right there or he's just sorry to say
just doesn't respect her like at all
yeah but he does though because he must
have respected her to ask her in the
first place
he asked me three times three times
twice three times I mean how many times
do girls ask for a ring and they get it
a lot of the times
they'll ask for girls girls and guys
have arguments about getting married all
the time women are always nagging on men
to get married and they give in but no
one second guesses that yeah
so was signing a contract that could
ruin your life men commit suicide over
divorce yeah that's one of the number
one predictors of suicide if a guy gets
divorced
so that's pretty serious
yeah well I mean they can always say no
and so could she yeah but I feel like
she was just too traumatized to even
talk yeah honestly when it was happening
how is your brain even processed there I
wanted to test is that why you couldn't
leave at the same time
she just said she wanted to test his
boundaries at the same time so obviously
it was a game set him up man you don't
do that
that makes more sense like that
it makes more sense if you say he was
testing his boundaries
because like you just said that he was
testing her boundaries but you never
questioned if she was testing hers but
this one I think this is like we
automatically like take the woman's side
yeah yeah yeah yeah and it's the same
thing with the with the marriage thing
like no one ever thinks about you know
any men are like twisted their arm yeah
walk down the aisle
huh I don't know I personally wouldn't I
personally wouldn't want to force my man
like if someone's gonna marry me I want
them to marry me because they want to
marry me yeah I agree but that's not
that's not everyone
well then they shouldn't be with that
woman yeah
that's why but we just spoke about the
fact how the majority of women don't
find the majority of men attractive so I
reckon there's more pressure on the guy
to think God if I don't marry this one
yeah
that is true I don't think it's fair
like you can't put the same standards on
men and women we're not equal I think
everyone here is grounded enough to know
that and you know women like you know
women want to get married but you know
if a man a man doesn't really know if he
wants to get married and the woman's
asking and asking and asking and he's
probably average looking knowing that
what 80 of women are gonna find him
unattractive like it's not the same and
men don't talk about their emotions very
much and they're like that doesn't
surprise me that divorce
um is a really high indicator of male
suicide because men don't talk to anyone
really and like if they don't can't talk
to their wife it's just it's devastating
you can't put you can't say it's the
same like all he shouldn't have said yes
because he's got way more to lose he
knows that he might not find someone
else whereas if you get divorced as the
female you'll find someone in minutes if
you go on social media
you ever hear that like 80 year old on
Tinder and she still was getting more
sweatshirts yeah
yeah
but Grandma what are you doing why'd you
do that interview yeah
um okay I'm gonna Read Super chats one
more time guys